Are you in the mood for to watch something
featuring wayward astronauts, robots on the fritz,
or cursed-filled murder investigations? Well,
you're in luck because the films of 2021 have
exactly that, and more, to offer you! Keep
watching to discover 2021's best sci-fi movies.
Stowaway is an existentially fraught
sci-fi drama that was released on
Netflix back in April. The plot sends three
astronauts to Mars on a two-year mission
and then throws a major wrench into their
plans when a stowaway is discovered on-board.
Director Joe Penna has assembled a great
cast. Toni Collette plays the ship's leader
on her final journey in space, Anna
Kendrick is the medical researcher,
and Daniel Dae Kim is the ship's
biologist. Unbeknownst to them,
an unwitting, injured stowaway played by
Shamier [shuh-MEER] Anderson is also onboard,
and whatever caused his predicament has also
damaged the ship's life-support controls, leaving
enough oxygen for only three people. One must go,
or they all die. So the question is: who takes
that final spacewalk? Variety's Owen Gleiberman
[GLEE-ber-muhn] had high praise as he declared,
"Penna takes a mission to Mars and unfurls
it on a direct and intimate emotional level.
We always feel the characters could be us."
Meanwhile, Christy Lemire
of RogerEbert.com called it:
"A clever take on a familiar genre
[ZHAHN-ruh] with a terrific cast."
So if you're in the mood for a sci-fi flick
that'll challenge you philosophically and make
you wonder what you would do in a life-threatening
situation, then you better check out Stowaway.
The Mitchells vs. the Machines is a
kid-friendly animated adventure that
hit Netflix on April 30. It features the voices
of Abbi Jacobson, Danny McBride, Maya Rudolph,
and Michael Rianda [ree-AN-duh],
who also directed and co-wrote.
They play a family on a road trip that turns into
an apocalyptic fight against a robotic revolution.
The emphasis on technology-as-villain grounds the
film squarely in sci-fi territory as the Mitchells
are thrust into a cell phone war after they've set
aside their gadgets for an old-fashioned vacation.
The Mitchells vs. the Machines
was a hit with critics,
and it was also produced by the
high-powered team of Phil Lord
and Christopher Miller. Bob Strauss of
the San Francisco Chronicle called it:
"A machine apocalypse for the whole family."
Meanwhile, The Guardian's Benjamin Lee noted,
"Rianda makes an earnest stab at trying to offer
up a balanced view of the pros and cons of iPhone
culture. Rather than the easier and clumsier
film he could have made scolding kids for
swiping and tapping and missing out on real life,
he shows that young digital creators are achieving
incredible things and that, when used right, this
form of connectedness can be a powerful force."
Oxygen, the latest from director Alexandre Aja
["Alexander" AH-zhuh], is being hailed as a taut,
engaging thriller. In this French-language film,
a woman named Liz wakes up in a cryogenic pod,
with no knowledge of who or where
she is. Her only companion is an AI
who advises her that the oxygen levels of
the pod are decreasing at alarming levels.
If Liz can't figure out what's going
on fast enough, she'll suffocate.
Aja is best known for creature features like
Piranha 3D and Crawl, but this time around
he's earning praise for his restraint. Filmed
during COVID lockdown, Oxygen eschews his usual
viscera for more existential dread. As David
Rooney of The Hollywood Reporter declared,
"While cult followers of Aja's extreme
horror might be let down by his turn
toward more measured sci-fi, there's
plenty of creepy unease packed into
his execution of a simple scenario
that grows increasingly complicated."
Special praise must all be given to lead actress
Mélanie Laurent [MEL-uh-nee luh-RONT]; in a
movie that's totally focused on one person,
you need an emotional, powerhouse
performance, and that's what she delivers.
A Quiet Place Part II ["two"] is the
long-awaited sequel to the 2018 original
that had its theatrical-exclusive release
on May 28, 2021. This creepy sci-fi flick
was quickly certified fresh at Rotten Tomatoes,
earning praise from critics and audiences alike.
Director-screenwriter-star John Krasinski's
[kruh-ZIN-skee] continuation of the Abbott
family's story provides a glimpse of the first
day that the sonic aliens arrived. Krasinski's
real-life wife Emily Blunt returns as mom
Evelyn, who journeys with her newborn infant and
two older children in search of a new place to
live after their farm becomes uninhabitable.
They eventually come across Cillian [KIL-ee-uhn]
Murphy's Emmett, a friendly acquaintance briefly
seen in the opening events of the film.
Alas, Emmett is now withdrawn and sullen,
and our heroes don't know if they can
trust him, but they need his help.
A Quiet Place Part II has earned praise for its
superior use of tension and its tight script.
The performances are incredible across
the board, with Bloody Disgusting's Meagan
Navarro lavishing specific praise on deaf actress
Millicent [MIL-uh-suhnt] Simmonds by declaring,
"This is above all Simmonds'
show, and she nails it."
If you were worried whether or not the
sequel would live up to the first film,
you can rest assured that it's
another scary, silent treat.
"Run."
Chinese-Taiwanese sci-fi mystery flick
The Soul arrived on Netflix on April 14.
It doesn't have a lot of reviews in the U.S., but
it's nevertheless hitting a chord with audiences.
Set in a near future when cars hum with
electricity and holograms pop out of buildings,
The Soul tells the story of a prosecutor who has
cancer and whose detective wife is newly pregnant.
Despite his illness, they work together to solve
the murder of a tycoon. Was it his young wife who
killed him, or his alienated son, or his partner,
who's invented a way to revive dying neurons with
a special powder? Or is it the result of a curse
that his first wife placed on him before she died?
The story focuses on the interactions of
the characters amidst the sci-fi and occult
trappings. Daniel Hart of
Ready Steady Cuts declared,
"This is a real, well-woven mystery
that wants to provoke the audience
with thoughts rather than events,
which makes it even more fascinating."
Meanwhile, JK Sooja of Common Sense Media opined,
"This film [has] slick production, strong acting,
and [an] intricate plot. Quite simply, the
central mystery in The Soul is captivating."
Ryan Reynolds is the inimitable star of Free
Guy, which arrived in theaters back in August.
He plays a guy named Guy, who spends every single
day greeting his goldfish, drinking coffee,
and going to his job at the bank, where he talks
with his best friend, security guard Buddy,
played by Lil Rel Howery. But Guy has no idea
that he's stuck in a predetermined loop as a
non-player character in a popular video game.
That is, until he meets Molotov Girl, aka Millie,
and becomes enamored with her. Millie, played
by Jodie Comer, wants to prove that powerful
video game impresario Antwan stole the game that
she developed with her friend Keys. Can Guy help
Millie get proof before Antwan destroys the game,
as well as Guy, Buddy, and all their NPC friends?
Since its release, Free Guy has
been earning raves from critics.
Charlotte O'Sullivan of The Standard,
for one, praised its humor, as she said,
"[It's] knowing rather than nasty and, even at its
most surreal, avoids coming across as indulgent."
Meanwhile, USA Today's Brian Truitt called it a:
"Big, warm hug of a movie with plenty to love."
And Robert Daniels of The
Playlist declared simply,
"Free Guy is a winner."
"Is that a Glock in your pocket?"
"No." "What?!" "It's two Glocks."
Director James delivered his take on DC
super-villains in 2021 with The Suicide
Squad. Less a sequel to 2016's Suicide Squad and
more a reboot, the film brings back Harley Quinn,
Amanda Waller, Captain Boomerang, and Rick Flag,
while adding a whole slew of new characters,
including the likes of Bloodsport, Peacemaker,
Ratcatcher 2, Polka-Dot Man, and King Shark.
And that's just barely scratching the surface.
Once again, Waller offers a ragtag group of
supervillains the chance to shave time off their
prison sentences by completing a secret mission
for her. If they go off script, she'll blow off
their heads. What follows is a lot of mayhem,
a lot of swearing, and a lot of gory fun.
The Seattle Times' Soren Andersen raved,
"Gunn masterfully mixes humor and bloodshed and
manages to give a surprising number of characters
room to develop their personas. And when it
comes to staging set pieces, he's at his best."
Meagan Navarro of Bloody
Disgusting concurred, as she wrote,
"It's endearingly sweet, even as it's spilling
brain matter and gore by the bucket load."
"Bird."
Filmed on an iPhone during the COVID-19
lockdown, British film Infinitum:
Subject Unknown features themes
both timely and timeless.
Written by married couple Matthew and
Tori Butler-Hart and directed by Matthew,
it stars Tori as Jane, an amnesiac woman trapped
in a parallel world and a time loop. The film
features cameos from Sir Ian McKellen and Conleth
Hill of Game of Thrones, both of whom may have
information that could help Jane regain her memory
and return to her own world before time runs out.
Infinitum: Subject Unknown has been praised
specifically for Tori's performance.
Rachael Harper at SciFiNow, for one, wrote,
"She shoulders [the] responsibility [of
being alone on screen] incredibly well."
While Keri O'Shea of Warped Perspective raved,
"[Bulter-Hart] pitches [her acting] perfectly
given the situations unfolding around her,
and she does most of it without saying anything."
The film is notable for how it tackles its
heavy and horrific themes in a surreal and
unique manner. So if you're looking for a sci-fi
flick that's more on the intense side of things,
then definitely add Infinitum:
Subject Unknown to your watch list.
Frank Herbert's 1965 novel Dune has long been
considered unfilmable, but people keep trying.
There was the 1984 David Lynch version,
followed by the 2000 TV miniseries, and now,
its latest cinematic incarnation is a sumptuous
feast for the eyes and ears. Director Denis
Villeneuve [den-NEE vill-NUHV] wisely presents
only a portion of the source material in a way
that's both satisfying as a movie in itself
and as an introduction of the events to come.
It's the year 10191, and House Atreides
[ah-TRAY-dees] is tasked by the Emperor
to replace the ruthless Harkonnens
[HAR-kuh-nens] as overseers of the
planet Arrakis [uh-RAH-kis], harvesting the
planet's coveted spice and keeping an eye
on the Fremen [FREM-uhn], the indigenous
population whom the Harkonnens brutally
oppressed. The Harkonnens are less than
pleased, and conflict ensues. Audiences
and critics alike have fallen in love with
Dune. Salon's Melanie McFarland called it:
"A gorgeous sensory immersion that
holds us in its spell for hours,
with an ending that sparks
yearning to see what comes next."
The Houston Chronicle's Cary Darling raved,
"Dune is an impressive feat,
a plunge into a richly designed world that
feels at once ancient and futuristic."
And The A.V. Club's Ignatiy Vishnevetsky
[ig-NAH-tee vish-nuh-VET-skee] noted that
although the story may feel "inconclusive" as is,
"The resulting film is a rarity among the overlong
effects-heavy blockbusters of the last decade:
One actually wishes it
didn't have to end so soon."
"Dune is very rich. It's an adventure
movie. It's a coming-of-age movie."
A basic "meaning of true friendship" tale
gets a digital upgrade in the animated feature
Ron's Gone Wrong. Lonely Barney, voiced by Jack
Dylan Grazer, gets his very own B-bot named Ron,
voiced by Zach Galifianakis [gal-ih-fuh-NAK-is].
B-bots are advertised as a kid's "best friend out
of the box" that connects to all their favorite
apps. What could possibly go wrong? Well, Ron
could go wrong. Barney's father and grandmother
can't afford the expensive companion, but they
luck into one that's literally fallen off a
truck. The damage from the fall causes Ron to act
unlike any other B-bot, which soon comes to the
attention of Bubble, the company that sells them.
Bubble's COO Andrew isn't pleased, and it's not
long before Bubble is after Ron to destroy him.
While its box office receipts haven't been
great, Ron's Gone Wrong has impressed almost
everyone who bought a ticket to see it. Angie
Han [HAHN] at The Hollywood Reporter noted,
"What [it] lacks in daring imagination,
it makes up for with endearing good humor,
thoughtful cultural critique,
and one heck of a cute robot."
And The Washington Post's Pat Padua
praised the film's family appeal, noting,
"Ron's Gone Wrong has plenty of slapstick and
potty humor for kids. But adults will also be
intrigued by its frequently scathing (albeit
somewhat conflicted) critique of consumerism."
Simply put, you'll be wrong if you
don't check out Ron's Gone Wrong.
"Friend request. Friend request."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.